the father of the kid wants you to keep
it should he have any say
if I was in a serious relationship
um
I mean of course he can have his opinion
but
I think like I said it's
down to the woman
to do whatever she wants to do so even
if he said no I don't want you to get an
abortion I think even if she wants to
get one she should still be able to get
one because at the end of the day it's
hey let's carry in the baby
um yeah
okay let's give them both so yeah I
think it's his choice yeah I would agree
with you and also like who's human
rights are we
thinking about here you know your whole
life changes if you have a baby
like if you run out for a woman yeah for
all parties involved they're not even
just the man and the woman the superior
The Wider family and the child what if
the dad says like uh you don't once you
give birth like you don't have to I'll
take care of it I don't I don't need you
to do anything else like I got it can
you carry it for me can you buff it for
me
can you change your body for me
do you know how many times you hear
about like dads running out on like
single like mums and they're like oh I
swear it took two of us to meet this kid
like come back here and like look after
the kid so that is acceptable for the
woman to say but when it comes to like
deciding on who's like gonna have the
baby no no it's definitely my choice
this is what I mean and then like oh
like I didn't even expect us to go into
the whole men and women's type of debate
and I thought we were gonna stick to
abortion but it's again like it's just
double standards isn't it you know you
guys want basically everything and then
more and you don't carry it you don't
have to you don't you don't carry it but
what's worse though carrying it or
paying for it for the rest of its life
and paying non-stop child support paying
everyone so you're saying that women
don't pay for their children
well I'm saying no most of the time if
the man is involved he's paying for very
much everything right if he's a student
no if he's a supporting that if he's
disappointed as supporting means
supporting the person that's actually
doing
sorry
if I'm in the kid's life I'm gonna have
to make sure I'm working to look after
that kid subjectively yeah not
objectively wait hold on say that again
that's you subjectively yeah well I'm
just talking about what a high value man
would want to do for their wife I don't
want personally a high value man would
want to do but statistically is that
what happens well yeah so why there's so
many single mothers in this country man
no they're single mothers because women
are irresponsible
like in terms of what do you mean like
irresponsible it's actually you're in
control of who you have sex with you are
so if you've chosen to have sex with a
man that isn't someone that would
actively support you that makes you what
exactly irresponsible you're responsible
for
any kind of choice yeah because yeah you
have you have 10 choices the men have
one you you have the choice like you
know when you're ovulating you have the
choice to get an abortion you have 41
forms of birth control to choose from
the man has condom or no condom
that's a choice right
you're right but I'm saying I'm saying
the women have more Choice than the men
so it's more on us we're in control of
who who we have sex with so coming back
to the original question was like should
man have a choice when it comes to
abortion 100 based on that opinion um
right I mean you guys are possible
equality right so why can't we go house
pearls just literally said with her home
words that's our responsibility so why
would you get a safe responsibility I
said it's um we have more choices so we
are more responsible so if we're more
responsible why do we not have the same
percentage of choice okay but you're
only having that large percentage of
toys while it's in your stomach right
and that's all you're debating but what
happens when it comes out yeah I said
who's who's responsible for birth yeah
pregnancy birth both plus I feel like
it's hot like it's the egg and the sperm
it's not just yeah it's like half half
right so it's like it takes two to tango
right but if it's 50 50 then why are we
more responsible because we carry it
I'm saying if there's an unplanned
pregnancy like we as women we have so
much more Choice than the men so like we
can we can do abstinence if we want like
we all could have waited till we were
married you know we we can also um we
also have the choice to require the men
that we sleep with wear condoms we could
do that we could also we also have the
choice to get on birth control you can
get an IUD you can get a pill that thing
in your arm I know there's side effects
but that's that's our choice right
um on top of that we also can be wise
with who we sleep with and not sleep
with anyone that wouldn't be not a good
father we also have the choice to get an
abortion we also have the choice to put
a man on child support we also have the
choice to get married and leave and then
take half
um we also get more child support if we
take away the kids from the dad so we're
financially incentivized to take away
the children so they have all of the we
have all of this choice and the men have
condom or no condom so it's like if we
have 10 choices that's a pre-pregnancy
choice that the man has post pregnancy
Choice it would depend a lot a lot of
the things yeah of course we have that
choice but divorce doesn't just get you
don't just automatically get half based
on absolutely nothing like if you're a
woman that's like worked and certain
amount of money it does come down
somewhere yeah and certain numbers
there's there's a small percentage of
women but women don't typically make
more than men that we we make less and
we spend more and there's also um I just
learned about this the other day there's
um lawsuits going on in the U.S where
they overestimate how much it costs to
raise a child basically just so they can
get more child support in court so
they'll say like it costs this much to
raise a child even though like for
example let's do Kanye West and Kim
Kardashian like why does that girl and
and she out earns him and he's a
billionaire and he still has to pay how
much in child support yeah 200k a month
and that's a billionaire woman so what
happens to the average man if if a
multi-millionaire that married a
billionaire can't escape child support
so you believe that a man shouldn't have
any say in an abortion or [ __ ] based on
the fact that you acknowledge
no I'm saying like we're more
responsible for an unplanned pregnancy
like it's more of our fault
and we actually avoid the responsibility
after because we get we make the men pay
for our poor choices so you think that
they should have more say in abortions
or not
um I think that abortion if it was up to
me it would be illegal yeah so
um I don't think anyone should ever say
but if it was to be that what would be
your like if that if abortions were not
illegal and you were on the side of uh
approach that was pro-choice you would
think that it would have to be a
signature from the man and the woman
for unable to enable the actual like
surgical or procedure to continue based
on the facts
um
but see that's hard because I wouldn't
even I wouldn't be pro-choice to begin
with so why is the question like
relevant why because you're pro-choice
that's what I was asking yeah
um but if if you're pro-life like you
don't believe in abortion to begin with
so you wouldn't even get there so it's
not about the masculine and feminist
purely based on it's just like like
feminist fought for equality here it is
what guys are guys that are for pro-life
right so when I got pregnant twice I was
actually on um anti- contraception
um how would you how would you react to
that like obviously
um I was on pills okay yeah and I was
taking them regularly and both of the
times I even changed my pills just to
make sure you know if a different one
and and both of the times I actually got
pregnant so it's it's kind of difficult
like when you actually don't stretch
after the first time
um what do you mean after the first like
pregnancy you didn't switch birth
control I did I did that's why I said I
tried different ones yeah and then the
the other one is a different one and it
still didn't work and I looked
specifically just to check like I made
sure that I took one I even had an alarm
set you know and it is what would you
say to them I'm curious why don't you
get an IUD that's like that's the most
effective one also um
I don't know oh is that what you guys
call here the corner yeah I had a clue I
had a coil
um but it went um it got stuck um and I
couldn't breathe I had to they didn't
even know that it um it was that it was
stuck under it was attached to one of
the womb tissues or something it was so
painful and I kept saying like
something's wrong and they were like no
nothing's wrong you ain't had children
so it's it's not that you know and I had
to actually go privately pay for X-rays
and then they told me no it's that and
they had to to get it out I mean I just
think um you also only ovulate three
days a month so I think you can track
your ovulation um I think you can wear
condoms and I think you cannot have sex
yeah that's another thing but yeah and I
just think like I'm just a big fan of
like you kind of made your bed lie in it
and at some point like something went
wrong yeah
um but you can't see I can I come in I
don't see it from the same perspective
as you know
I know a lot of people that's like you
know just trying to justify you know I I
was on the pill and all this um simple
biology
sex
creates like children can not always but
it's it's cause and effect and I just
think we've and I get it I say this as a
as someone who who got pregnant and had
a child at 22 that typical age
um and um yeah it's like
is is we've lost
we've lost that in society it's like
it's my right to have sex with who I
want and
um not have any consequences and and I
find it hard to say that word
consequently because I
I was I was silly I made a mistake but I
have been blessed with a child and I've
got a beautiful daughter so I I don't
see it as oh that was my punishment or
that was my you know for for for being
careless
um but it's just I think we just need to
get back to the place of society is just
looking at what sex is and you know if
you don't want to have a child then
maybe
sex should be like you know if if you're
not ready to have a child then you know
that is also pleasure and having
Recreation so it's both it's two things
it's not just one yeah and but what's
what if you can have a child then surely
you want to ensure that the person
you're having sex with is someone that
you would be happy to have and raise a
child with
because because the opposite to that is
what we're left with today right I think
that's what we need to be able to kill
that's definitely a female perspective
because a guy is not going to just have
sex with a woman who he's hoping to have
a baby with he's just gonna have sex
with a woman because yeah yeah like I I
just think like you can wear condoms
like if you're on okay I'll give it to
you if you have
condoms and birth control and you
tracked your cycle I will give you that
l oh but it's like if you didn't do all
three things like You're irresponsible
at some point
oh no I think she was trying to say um
because you said it was for you said it
was for pleasure and I'm saying yeah if
you want to have sex for pleasure fine
um you can do that but like be careful
and and I just think like if you didn't
do all three of those things like at
some point you were irresponsible as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible